this episode of legal eagle was made
possible by skill share learned to think
like a lawyer for free for two months by
clicking on a link in the description as
if it wasn't bad enough already that
people have fallen ill from the
coronavirus businesses are closing
quarantined and some states are on
complete lockdown now we have senators
allegedly profiteering off of this
worldwide pandemic four senators have
now been alleged to have engaged in
insider trading by liquidating or
trading stocks just weeks before a
massive sell-off in the market due to
coronavirus panic senators Richard Burr
Kelly Lafleur Dianne Feinstein and Jim
Inhofe have all been accused of selling
stocks after getting inside information
two of the four Burr and La Fleur took
part in a classified and non public
hearing regarding the corona virus and
it's looming impact those two senators
Richard Burr a senator from North
Carolina and chairman of the Senate
Intelligence Committee and Kelly Lafleur
a newly appointed senator from Georgia
sold significant amounts of stock at the
same time they were receiving non-public
classified information about the
severity of the corona virus and its
potential devastating impact worldwide
at the same time that they may have been
downplaying the effects of the corona
virus to the public if these allegations
are true is this a crime well we're
about to find out
[Music]
hey legal eagles it's time to think like
a lawyer and maybe get out the
pitchforks and guillotines because it
might be time for some senatorial heads
to roll today we're going to discuss
what happens when senators abuse their
position and profit off of a massive
tragedy or is this all just a big
misunderstanding
now to better understand what senators
Burr and Loffler are being accused of
it'll be helpful to have a little
background as to what insider trading is
and how it developed into its current
form the Securities and Exchange Act of
1934 was enacted with a desire to
promote fairness and clarity in the
federal securities laws for all
participants in the financial market
section 10b of the Exchange Act was
intended to be the exchange acts broad
anti-fraud provision designed to cover
the full range of fraudulent conduct
that quote human ingenuity can devise of
course humans are very ingenuitive when
it comes to defrauding other people the
Supreme Court has recognized that 10b
was designed as a catch-all Clause to
prevent fraudulent practices now it's
from this statute that the concept of
insider trading was born although the
concept of insider trading emerged in
the 60s it really wasn't until the 1980s
that the US Supreme Court affirmed that
insider trading was in fact a violation
of section 10 B after insider trading
was deemed legal what developed were
sort of two types and reasons for
insider trading the classical theory and
the more expansive misappropriation
theory now the classical theory of
insider trading specifically holds that
corporate insiders are liable when they
use material nonpublic information
obtained from their unique position with
Ana Corporation for their own personal
advantage in the securities market as
the SEC has noted there is an inherent
unfairness and allowing a corporate
insider to use non-public information to
the detriment of other innocent
investors in securities markets the
Supreme Court has reasoned that an
individual must refrain from trading
securities on the basis of non-public
information because of their fiduciary
relationship with shareholders as a
corporate insider now that really only
applies to corporate insiders and you
can imagine that there's all kinds of
insider trading that doesn't actually
involve someone inside the company
itself which is why the Supreme Court
later adopted what's now known as the
misappropriation theory of insider
trading which extended liability to
certain corporate Outsiders that traded
on confidential information in breach of
some duty owed to the source of
information not
Sara Lee the shareholders themselves the
Supreme Court has held that under a
misappropriation theory an individual
breaches a duty to the owner of
confidential information by using that
information to his or her advantage in
the stock market it's called
misappropriation theory because it's
kind of like stealing you are taking
information that doesn't belong to you
and using it for your own advantage this
often comes up in what are called tipper
or Tippie cases essentially one who
receives an inside tip and trades that
non-public information received from a
tipper they're liable under Section 10b
of the exchange act regardless of
whether or not there was any benefit to
the person that provided the tip itself
now that's all in the corporate context
but what about members of Congress
Congress people are privy to a whole
host of classified and non-public
information that most of us are
completely unaware of they're not
corporate insiders in the classical
sense but they still have information at
their fingertips that can easily be used
for their own personal gain so what
happens when someone in Congress makes
an investment decision in the stock
market based on this potentially
classified or top-secret information
would they be liable under some form of
insider trading well the answer for a
long time was effectively no Congress
basically had this absurd loophole that
made insider trading legal and even
aboveboard with congressional ethics
rules this is what happens when the rule
makers make rules about themselves and
the statistics show just how
advantageous this was for them while
traders were beating the market by
approximately 5% and hedge funds by
seven to eight percent in one study
published by the Journal of financial
and quantitative analysis it showed that
Congress people were beating the market
by an astounding 12 percent and what's
even more astounding than their returns
is Congress's brazenness with which they
were cashing in former Senator John
Kerry is a prime example of cashing in
on non-public information for instance
on May 15 2007 the government ended
reimbursements of an obscure anemia drug
manufactured by Amgen which caused the
company's stock to tank but you know who
sold all of their Amgen stock just days
before yep that's right former
presidential candidate Senator John
Kerry he avoided almost any loss by
selling all of his stock on May 4th and
May 5th just days before the ramp
Christman's ended impeccable timing of
course Kerry had similar good fortune
when it came to the rollout of Obamacare
Kerry was a member of the Senate Finance
Committee Subcommittee on health and
played a key role in developing
President Obama's health care reform
legislation but isn't about eating
broccoli folks and just prior to the
enactment of the ACA Kerry bought stock
in big-time winners that resulted from
Obamacare such as pharmaceutical
companies Teva and ResMed medical device
manufacturer and at the same time Kerry
dumped stock in the health insurance
industry which suffered greatly as a
result of the passage of Obamacare
however no example is worse or more
appalling than that a former
representative Spencer Bachus during the
financial crisis of 2008 Baucus was a
ranking member on the Financial Services
Committee and on September 18 2008
Baucus received a private briefing on
the collapsing economy and financial
system from none other than the chairman
of the Federal Reserve at the time Ben
Bernanke and the Treasury secretary Hank
Paulson armed with information that
practically no one else knew about what
else could Baucus possibly do with it
well he invested heavily in the market
feeling Baucus effectively shorted the
market by buying options that would only
rise if the market tanked and a few days
later the market went down as
anticipated and Baucus nearly doubled
his money so in an attempt to clear up
Congress's responsibilities under the
Exchange Act and a natural extension of
the misappropriation theory Congress
passed what is known as the stock act
the stock Act is short for the stop
trading on congressional knowledge Act
and was passed in April of 2012 during
the presidency of Barack Obama and it
made it illegal for members of Congress
to make investment decisions based on
non-public information they obtained in
their unique political positions that is
you can't make trades in the stock
market based on classified information
received in meetings and briefings that
were meant to aid politicians and making
decisions for the good of the public now
prior to this act the SEC held that
government information had no connection
with insider trading of course you might
say that as well if the people using
this information were also the same
people that controlled your funding but
this hugely bipartisan bill was
supported by a vote of 96 to 3 only 3
senators voted against this act that
would prohibit Congress from financially
benefitting off of class
information of course one of those three
senators ironically was Senator Richard
burr who as we noted is currently being
accused of insider trading himself you
really can't make this up so let's talk
about the illustrious senator from the
great state of North Carolina Senator
Richard Burr was recently privy to
classified information about how
potentially dangerous and devastating
the corona virus outbreak could be way
before it was on the radar of any of us
everyday folks in the United States in
addition to being a senator with access
to significant amount of classified
information on the corona virus Burt
himself had a unique understanding what
was going on because of his role as the
chairman of the Senate Intelligence
Committee and the daily briefings on the
corona virus that he received in fact
burb might be considered something of an
expert in biohazard threats and actually
helped to write the pandemic and
all-hazards preparedness Act which forms
the framework for the federal response
to the very situation that we're dealing
with right now in terms of the corona
virus so what did ver do with this vital
information and his unique expertise did
he warn the public and insure them that
despite the administration's downplaying
of the threat that the American public
was aware of what was going on so they
could be prepared as best as possible no
it doesn't seem so it seems that around
the time that burr was first made aware
of this information on potential future
impact of the corona virus he sold off
nearly one point six million dollars of
his stocks portfolio in fact on one day
alone February 13th burst sold personal
stocks worth between six hundred and
twenty-eight thousand and one point
seven two million dollars in
thirty-three separate transactions to
give you a frame of reference that is
the most stock he's sold in a single day
in 14 months his timing was of course
impeccable as a week after burrs sales
the stock market began a sharp decline
and has lost at least 30% of its value
ever since and what makes this even more
interesting is that not only did he sell
a bunch of personal stocks at this time
large quantities of those sales were in
industries that have been hit
significantly hard by the pandemic like
one hundred and fifty thousand dollars
in the Wyndham Hotel and Resort stock
which has lost nearly two-thirds of its
value in fact Burr shared some of this
inside information of dire economic and
societal effects to only a select few in
late February while President Trump was
actively
downplaying any fears about kovat 19
this is a list of the different
countries United States is rated number
one most prepared on February 27th burr
addressed a group at the Tar Heel Circle
about the potential impact of the corona
virus in addressing companies and
organizations from North Carolina that
donated more than a hundred thousand
dollars to his election campaign burr
said we have seen in recent history it's
probably more kin to the 1918 pandemic
every company should be cognizant of the
fact that you may have to alter your
travel you may have to look at your
employees and judge whether the trip
they're making to Europe is essential or
whether it could be done on
videoconference burr went on to say
there will be I'm sure times that
communities probably some in North
Carolina have a transmission rate where
they say let's close schools for two
weeks everybody stay home these
statements were made 13 days before the
US State Department warned Americans
against international travel in more
than two weeks before North Carolina
decided to close at schools and an
apparent attempt to diffuse these
allegations a spokesman for Senator burr
stated senator burr filed a financial
disclosure form for personal
transactions made several weeks before
the US and financial markets showed
signs of volatility due to the growing
coronis outbreak the thing is that's
sort of what he's being accused of it
looks like he knew what was going to
happen before a lot of other people did
and then sold off the stocks whether he
disclosed the sale later on isn't
material to whether he traded on inside
congressional information by the way I
asked for recommendations for targeted
and effective charities regarding the
coronavirus on Twitter and you legal
eagles did not disappoint I wanted to
highlight one of them here the Gates
Foundation kovat 19 fund they focus on
vaccines diagnostics and therapeutics
which are going to be necessary for
ending this pandemic in fact there are
several funds that you can choose from
to get even more targeted and the Gates
Foundation has had a jump start on most
of us since they started focusing on the
corona virus in January and they have
general expertise in global health and
biomedical research I'll drop a link in
the description I just gave
hundred dollars if you're in a position
to give I would really appreciate it if
you could but on to the next criminal I
mean senator now senator burr wasn't the
only one potentially getting in on the
action of trading on inside information
another interesting case is that of
newly appointed senator Kelly Lafleur
from Georgia who is potentially the
richest member in Congress right now
Loffler whose husband Jeffrey Sprecher
is the chairman of the New York Stock
Exchange
she began aggressively selling equities
on January 24th the same day that she
was present for an all Senate briefing
conducted with the CDC director and
officials from the National Institute of
Allergy and Infectious Diseases over the
next few weeks
she and Sprecher sold stock to the tune
of potentially three million dollars and
it's important to note that from January
6th when she was selected to take the
place of Senator Isakson until the day
of this coronavirus briefing Loffler had
not made a single stock transaction from
that day through the middle of February
however her household dumped seven
figures worth of stocks in almost 30
separate transactions additional SEC
filings show that Sprecher sold an
additional 3.5 million in shares of his
own company IntercontinentalExchange on
February 26 which is also la fleurs
former employer the power couple then
went on to sell another fifteen point
three million shares in the same company
on March 11th and since the initial sale
of their stock in
IntercontinentalExchange the company's
stock prices almost dropped 25% they
then conveniently bought shares in
Citrix a company which makes teleworking
software at the same time there have
also been allegations against senator
Feinstein and Inhofe who have been
accused of dubiously selling large
amounts of stocks in the weeks prior to
the markets reaction to the coronavirus
those senators Feinstein and Inhofe were
not in attendance of the all Senate
briefing on the corona virus that
Loffler and Burr were present for in
addition senator Feinstein indicated
that her investments are actually held
in a blind trust that she has no control
over or even any oversight that being
said the timing of these trades still
raises questions that should probably be
investigated we lose sight of this
sometimes but the mere appearance of
impropriety shakes people's faith in our
institution but those are the
allegations against the four senators
though really we're only hearing one
song
this story source largely from a Daily
Beast article on this topic but what are
the potential defenses that these
senators might have to raise against
allegations of insider trading well of
course you have the standard insider
trading defenses such as the fact that
there was a disclosure prior to the use
of the material information or a lack of
knowledge that the material information
was actually confidential other
straightforward defenses can be used as
well like the argument that the person
never actually had possession of
material nonpublic information or the
classic my lawyer said it was okay
defense and courts have found insider
trading did not occur when the
transaction was part of a scheduled or
predetermined trading plan and we don't
necessarily know what any of these
particular senators had in terms of
financial planning there's actually a
constitutional defense that may be made
by members of Congress to under what's
known as these speeching bait clause the
text in the Constitution says that for
any speech or debate in either House
members of Congress shall not be
questioned in any other place that
Clause has been interpreted to provide a
certain criminal and civil immunity for
lawmakers when they're engaging in
official legislative acts that rule has
been used by members of Congress to
refuse to answer subpoenas and it would
be pretty likely that they would do so
if the SEC attempts to investigate any
of these allegations particularly if it
has to do with information that they
received in briefings on the coronavirus
and the factual defenses that burr and
Loffler have raised come from a couple
of different angles Loffler simply
contains that she simply didn't make the
trades and that they were done by a
third party financial adviser Loffler
defended herself on twitter by saying
this is a ridiculous and baseless attack
I do not make investment decisions for
my portfolio investment decisions are
made by multiple third party advisors
without my or my husband's knowledge or
involvement as confirmed in the periodic
transaction report to Senate Ethics I
was informed of these purchases and
sales On February 16 2020 three weeks
after they were made if you actually
look at the personal transaction reports
that were filed it notices at the bottom
that I'm only informed of my
transactions after they occur several
weeks also stated that the trades were
part of a larger purchase that included
a lot of stock that has subsequently
gone down there's a range of different
decisions made every day with regard to
my
savings and 401k portfolios that I'm not
involved in and certainly like any other
trades you you can't see into the future
bur however doesn't deny making the
trades but says he did so on public
information and his general concern for
the impact of the coronavirus the
specific statement he released stated I
relied solely on public news reports to
guide my decision regarding the sale of
stocks on February 13th
specifically I closely followed CNBC's
daily health and science reporting out
of its asia bureaus at the time
understanding the assumption many could
make in hindsight however I spoke this
morning with a chairman of the Senate
ethics committee and asked him to open a
complete review of the matter with full
transparency
now as possible both of these things
could be a complete defense if Loffler
can show that she never contacted the
third parties who made the trades on her
behalf then it seems unlikely that they
colluded in some fashion to trade on
inside information and if Burke and
somehow show that he never used
confidential information and making
those trades that might be a defense as
well but everyone has to sort of admit
that the timing on these trades is
highly suspicious
now if the allegations are true and the
implications turn out to be correct
Burr and Loffler put their portfolio
above the safety and well-being of their
fellow Americans that they were voted in
to represent and they would deserve more
significant consequences than simply not
being reelected they would need to be
held accountable for their actions but
beyond that I think Congress needs to
further rethink the restrictions on how
they're allowed to invest in office the
situation also goes to show the benefit
of having a blind trust a valid argument
could be made that Congress men and
women should never be active investors
but really should only be allowed to be
passively invested in ways in which they
cannot gain from the use of their
classified or non-public information and
a blind trust the owner or trust or of
the assets in theory has no knowledge of
the specific stock holdings in the trust
the only control the trust store has
over the trustees to initiate the trust
and to terminate it but having that
blind trust would inoculate the senators
from these kind of allegations that they
profited over
classified information that they
received this would obviously be a
burden to Congress people and Senators
but you know if you're elected to the
highest deliberative body in the country
you probably need to make some
sacrifices in order to hold that office
but in an interesting coda to this whole
thing their reports of the SEC will in
fact investigate these transactions so
we actually may learn more about these
suspicious trades after all you would
think that these Congress people would
be better at business and wouldn't need
to use classified information to make a
buck at the public's expense instead of
using their positions for personal gain
they should really take Michael chernow
Skillshare class entrepreneurship hustle
from business plan to real success
Michael would teach these senators how
to find market opportunity nailed their
business plan pitch investors align
brand and culture and measure success
you know in a way that isn't dollars
made shorting the market before the
coronavirus shuts it down and if they're
committing insider trading because
they're bad with money they could always
take Emily sim Cox's Skillshare class
bookkeeping for freelancers how to
handle your finances Skillshare is an
online learning community that has tens
of thousands of classes on everything
like music design technology and
business a yearly membership is less
than $10 per month but the first 500
legal eagles will get two free months of
Skillshare when you click using the link
below plus it really helps out this
channel it's a great way to learn just
about anything when we're all stuck
inside going crazy going crazy going
crazy crazy or going crazy the free
premium membership gives you unlimited
access to must know topic so you can
improve your skills and learn new things
all free for two months so just click
using the link in the description plus
clicking on the link really helps out
this channel did I say that before no
I'm I'm not going crazy crazy do you
agree with my grade leave your
objections in the comments and check out
my other real law reviews over here
where I cover all of the coronavirus
news of the day so click on this
playlist and I'll see you in court